hi [ __ ] did you miss yes I'm not
talking to them we already know I've
been with you all day I miss you I
missed you tonight I love you okay so
before I say anything else I want to say
hi and welcome back we've missed you so
much
on today's podcast we have Gina whoa
[Laughter]
I'm Tiffany yes oh yeah you had aa girl
Jessica because I'm realizing what we're
about to talk about yes so so so so so
excited because today we have her Audi a
cop for the Elly County yes I said that
correctly all she is a police officer
yeah so dope she's a badass and the
reason why jess is kind of like Carling
in her skin a little bit cuz we all know
she's she inside she has inside
information insider information inside
her information I hope you got that yes
I also put this out there that this is
her Audi's first time doing anything in
front of the camera yeah yeah no of
course she's [ __ ] hot who would not
know they're gonna be like oh my god
like what do I follow I said you can't
see up close for her eyes are gray and
they're gorgeous holy yeah so I just
want to kick it off okay this let's do
it yeah um so how did this all come
about how long have you been a cop how
were you like yup I want to put my life
in danger for the sake of the rest of
the world like any okay so I'm 26 years
old
I've been a cop for three years when I
was in college getting always my a
senior in college I was getting my
bachelor's in human services and I
minored in criminal justice so I've
always had an interest in law
enforcement but I never really like got
to see what it was about so my last year
in college I had to do an internship I
started interning for a station and they
exposed me to everything a DUI check
entering the 9-1-1 phone calls and then
I did my first ride-along so I went out
did my first ride-along and I loved it
so pretty oh my god I want to come for a
ride-along if I went on a ride-along I'd
be in the back so when I went on my
first ride-along I loved it and I was
like okay this this is fun like this is
what you do but of course you all get
that question like aren't you scared
like aren't just here you're gonna die
yes I am I was scared but I'm RELIGIOUS
and I'm Catholic I told myself hey at
the end of the day only God knows when
it's time to go and oh damn that's nice
you just see it's unpredictable so I
wanted to do something that every day
was going to be different and being a
cop every day is different even though
I'm responding to the same type of a
domestic violence call it is never going
to be the same demence call it can be
the females the aggressor or the Mo's
the aggressor you just never know and
every day is different and that's what I
liked exciting yes during her first
ride-along was it that hooked you
well one when I was getting my degree I
wanted to help people I knew I wanted to
do something so at first I wanted to be
a therapist for families and I was like
okay but then obviously you have to
think about the money like okay how much
am I gonna make and then I would still
needed to have gotten my masters and
then take the state license test so that
was going to take more time and then I
saw what a cop did for my particular
department and I was like hey like I'm
gonna be making way more money and I'm
not gonna be in depth anymore so I'm
gonna do this so that's pretty much what
made it for me like okay the salary yes
money girl like when I was growing up or
when I was in college I wanted to go to
Japan cuz I'm like I wanted to just
leave the country cuz like I just grew
up in a really strict household right so
I'm like what can I do where my parents
are gonna let me go out so then I found
like kind of a loophole for me which was
go to college and then there they have a
program where you can teach English
abroad and I'm like of course my parents
would definitely let me do that because
it's related to school right right but
they were like [ __ ] no that is
so [ __ ] dangerous how like what you
don't know they don't know the language
you don't know what can happen to you
your girl like you got a you'd like I
got to protect you this and that so I
can't even imagine telling my parents
hey well you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna be a cop and put myself I'm gonna
volunteer to put myself in danger like
how was that telling your panic my
family so pretty much my mom raised me I
have two brothers and I'm the only girl
I'm the middle child as well
so at first my mom was like what you're
crazy
my mom's spanish-speaking she's like
estas loca like you're crazy why would
you want to do that like you're gonna
put yourself in danger like you're my
only daughter and I was like mom it's
okay and I kind of told her the same
thing hey only God knows when it's time
and like this is I told her it was fun
and she's like you're crazy I mean at
the end of the day she supports me and
like slowly with time she was like okay
you're gonna be fine but she always
tells me hey if I don't put yourself in
a situation where you're gonna kill
yourself to get a bad guy
if he gets away feet gets away from you
today it's okay eventually that purse is
gonna get caught up like there when
someone's in batlike feet like they're
gonna end up at like don't kill yourself
so I always tell myself okay mom but she
still panics and she freaks out all the
time like tells me nothing
yes like praying I already see it coming
what cuz Jill won't do it but me can you
please put me on your old friend oh
because this [ __ ] won't do it alright I
just watched the movie and I just want
to be in someone's a friend of Geo Coco
you haven't opened em back cuz my family
never did that
No ah yes you [ __ ] is gonna be
forgotten then I wanna remember no
actually I got heard about it but once I
saw the movie I was like oh like we
don't really do that yeah everywhere
what everyone my fans at least okay my
family kind of does have one but it's
just like the Virgin Mary okay
but we don't put family photos and we
don't do the whole like flowers oh I
don't want to be in your son yeah I want
a nice one moving on yeah yeah sorry
girl I'll find one so when you came over
it was me and TIFF and you were over at
our house and I mean obviously we're so
curious cuz you're such a cute cute and
you just look like a like a very not
fragile you definitely don't look
fragile but you're just you don't look
like someone that I'd be intimidated of
or by so when we were like asking you a
bunch of questions and stuff and and it
came about that you once went undercover
yes please do tell your experience yes
I got very lucky and I got chosen to
work undercover my job yeah was to be a
decoy so I would portray to be a
commercial sex worker or a prostitute no
and maybe yes yeah I got the opportunity
to work undercover as a prostitute and
my job was one I did a lot of online
work to portray to be a commercial sex
worker and I like my thing was to look
for the pimps yeah
men or women because there are women
pens who would pander these young women
and a lot of times they would go after
the young gullible girls like hey they
would paint this perfect picture for
them hey I'm gonna buy you clothes gonna
take you to get your hair done your
nails done I'm gonna give you protection
and they'd would just paint this perfect
picture for these girls and hey you have
these sixteen seventeen year old girls
who their parents don't buy them
anything and then you meet this guy and
he's like hey I'm gonna give you all of
this so they they were the perfect bait
for them and sure enough they'd be super
nice to them and then they then you
would have what's called the gorilla
Pam's those are the pins that would beat
the girls they
the crap out of them and hey I need you
to bring me ten days excuse me ten dates
by tonight and yeah and these girls are
like and if they didn't bring what they
asked for them which would be their
quota then they would beat the girls and
a lot of these girls would be scared and
terrified from them I also got to work
in the women's jail where I met a lot of
these girls and I met this one girl in
particular she was young beautiful black
girl and she was like hey like I saw
that she was in jail for prostitution
and she just told me her life story and
she was like hey I've been a prostitute
my entire life and it's not because I
want to do it it's because I'm scared of
this guy yeah like why I'm here he's the
one that's putting money in my books and
I'm married she's like I'm married I
have a husband but see he's not even
funny in my books it's my favorite yeah
so she felt that hey he gives me he
supports me he gives me everything I
need so I have to go out there and do
what he tells me where would you find
these guys like is there like a like
online like chat room or something where
you're like hey little girl here
actually there's a lot of websites and a
lot of stuff is like things we use our
everyday Instagram so yeah so Craiglist
was one of them back page but the
government did the whole they shut that
down I think either last year some not
too long ago so that helped it a lot but
yeah you'd go on there's Instagram pages
girls some girls enjoy doing it they
enjoy being prostitutes and hoes because
it's easy money yeah it's easy money and
a lot of them get to charge a lot mm-hm
and then you have your snapchat it's
called are you trying to remember
premium yeah snapchat premium so pretty
much cuz you can send money through
snapchat they send you money and hey you
send them nudes videos whatever it is
that they want so you have that are you
sending nudes no no no yeah a decoy dude
there's only certain things I can do
like I could never do like cuz a lot of
them would want to confirm that you were
real so hey they'll talk to you they'll
call me like so I'd be at home and I'd
be like getting phone calls and I'd be
like pretending I was out on the blade
which is the street that they walk to to
get their dates
like oh I just got a date because they
would check on me to make sure I was a
real hoe wait how would they check like
do you see if you're on the streets
right no no they will call me like what
are you doing or how many dates do you
have how much money have you got in
because pimps ask their prostitutes for
what's called a choosing fee so in order
for them to be your Pam you have to pay
them yeah exactly because there are
protecting you and they're giving you
rides and doing all this so it's crazy
like we all know that prostitution is
out there but it's like a whole
different world a whole different
culture it's it's very big and a lot of
people are not aware of it like there's
a lot of girls that like now that I work
the streets um I write a lot of reports
where there's like 14 15 year old girls
that get contacted by these perverts
like they Instagram and yeah or somehow
you know on snapchat you can put your
location well these guys threading these
girls like hey if you don't send me
nudes right now like I'm gonna go kill
your family oh yeah so I've had a few
situation with that that's why I always
tell parents like monitor your kids
phone I think they're just you know
talking to their friends but they're not
like these guys are like it's crazy how
they're able to find these young girls
and these girls are global they get
attention from one guy and they're like
oh my god like I I've never gotten this
much attention from this guy but yet
this guy is a pervert he's freaking
massive just wants to like see your
small innocent body like it's hell yeah
I love you too yeah it groom young girls
like oh you're so mature for your age
yeah it makes the girls feel good yeah
yes they've never gotten that attention
so you see a lot of that so my job was
to go after those guys like be more
nasty like did you say you were 16 16
was like golden yeah I'd believe it yeah
so I would do that but my biggest thing
was to go after pimps because it's crazy
just the way they talked to women
they're very disrespectful and they
belittle you and in my head I was like
wow they mistreat these women yet
they're giving you their bad what would
he tell you like give us an example or
smile
no it's like legit yeah so it was
horrible there'd be times I'd have to
like mute my phone and be like oh my god
keep it together because you're trying
to arrest him for the mission I would
blow it ten out of ten times they [ __ ]
you [ __ ] I'm another would it take for
you to actually get these guys so in
order to meet the crime elements for
pandering equal one so pretty much when
I would wait for them to all contact me
I wanted them to take the initiative and
contact me first then I do simple
conversation and I kind of knew what
words to use and to know whether they
were a pimp or not or if they were just
some random where do trying to go didn't
you say those words are no I just be
like hey what's up and then be like oh
just trying to get some fast money oh
yeah like maybe like was money or I'd be
like he's like oh you want to hang out
oh and then I'd be like yeah and then I
put like a bunch of dollar signs that
means I'm gonna charge you to hang out
with me oh yeah should I'm gonna learn
how to be a prostitute oh yeah I mean
it's like legit out there and then when
they were pimps they knew what you were
talking about cuz you're talking their
language and when they were just random
dudes they would be like what are you
talking about like dili like okay focus
on this guy now but yeah pretty much
they have to tell you what they're
offering you like they're choosing fee
so how much they're gonna charge you are
they gonna watch what they charge yeah
on average going rate some with the
coupons going rate man every every guy
was different
some would say a thousand dollars some
would say 500 or some would say well how
many dates can get in a good night
meaning like you made a lot of money
then it'd be like okay give me half of
that or so they'll tell you that and
then they'll tell you also how much do
you get to keep out of the money that
money they tell you how much you can
keep yeah some will tell you give me all
your money and I'll take care of you or
someone be like oh you can keep 40 and
I'm gonna get 60 of whatever you make
every every pimp was diff
but they're [ __ ] they were all a so
so I learned that and I think the best
part was so once again my elements re
going back to you
the last one is meeting up with them
like I actually should attach them ya
know like you stand up and let me
explain a real quick or else bed we had
to start feel me later I would get all
the pimps please go to the you have to
see what Ritchie is wearing she looks
ridiculous they made me change really
fast and this is one of those ones that
you can't you can't snap at the bottom
so as I just put a lot in my pants I
would make it so I would charge so what
was it going wait what's it going rate
what what depends yeah I mean what was a
word that you used well like for a price
charge something yeah well you just give
them okay look a thousand bucks [ __ ] in
this outfit you're lucky to have me you
gotta buy [ __ ] them that has a proper
function to it okay like and speaking of
function funny I mention that we have to
do a little this is new for you but
we're gonna we're gonna pause really
quickly because we do have a sponsor
that we do want to say thank you to for
sponsoring this podcast and its function
of beauty and I'm absolutely freaking in
love with their shampoo and their
conditioner yeah it is like the best
shampoo I'm gonna show that I have ever
used in addition to smelling bomb as
though I have the peach one me too yeah
I got it so you can customize what you
want function to do for your hair so for
me for example I have normal hair cuz it
goes from like oily to super dry and
then there's normal and then I have wavy
hair so I'm like okay I do want it to be
a little bit like more wavy and then
what else did I ask for oh I want it to
be longer and then I want it to be
softer so you can really customize what
it is that you want your hair to do
function hooks you [ __ ] up I'm so happy
for it it's safe natural ingredients no
sulfates which is perfect to me because
I just did this is so fun
talked about my curls but I just got a
Brazilian Blowout girls are gone
specifically were like don't put any
shampoos with sulfates in it and I
immediately I was like well function
don't got that [ __ ] there's no parabens
there it has mineral oils and oh it
doesn't have minerals or any harmful
ingredients it's vegan and cruelty free
y'all favorite huh Gio's favorite yes my
absolute favorite and this is the
Internet's top-rated customized hair
brand over 20,000 five-star customer
reviews yes so if you guys want to try
out function of beauty I love it I use
the purple shampoo so I love it and it's
doing very well it's good for blonde oh
that's really good makes my hair really
usually your head smells really bad but
right anyway don't listen to do my hair
smells good no no no my hair I got you
back anyways great these listeners will
receive a 20% off their first order
that's a great discount to redeem head
to function of beauty calm slash b tch
and take their hair profile quiz again
go to function of beauty.com slash b tch
to get 20% off your custom formula Oh
awesome you can customize the color and
it puts your name yeah I'm sure
geo and function of Gina's dough you
didn't go for it if you hate Tiffany I
think I did put two affection okay good
after I said Tiffany I was like wait I
think we're back and we're talking about
award baby sugar daddy
she's the worst worse she wears because
she worked so hard she's too [ __ ]
independent for that [ __ ] as much as she
plays her I really want one though I
want sugar daddy so bad but I never go
out and try because I work so hard off
her ass you know I never getting offers
or anything either
is that legal no sugar I didn't think so
Oh daddy is not early edition I've never
I do not know
acting it always at me and please don't
arrest her yeah I really want a so why
is sugar daddy illegal like if no sexual
well they're gonna want sexual stuff but
what if their until they until they have
sex for money it's legal if there's
texting in pain I wanted to clarify so
how these things don't work out for me
how long were you undercover for nine
months Wow Wow that's me okay wait tell
me about your last phase the last phase
is when you go and you meet with them
and you said you don't you don't yeah
what are you you're Chris Hansen it
sorry go ahead what you wear those hey
nipple tassels so there is a time where
I actually have to walk the street but
I'll get into that right now very so
going back to you like the crime
elements whatever you have to meet them
in person to get to show that they had
the intent to meet us actually go out
there and pimp you or pander you so I
would be in a car and I have my phone
and I have his/her phone number be like
hey I would set up the location we're
meeting here so we will meet at that
location at the location we have a lot
of cops that are undercover as well hell
yeah oh my god I would feel like such a
[ __ ] by a boss ass [ __ ] it just
wasn't coming out I spoke over her story
and I didn't even say anything well I
can mention it anyway I'm sorry so then
once they told me hey I'm here then I
would be like okay well what kind of car
you in so I know what car I'm going
inside did you have a wire on you like
in the movies when I was walking yeah so
cool okay so then um once they said that
and I go I'm in a white car so we'll
look for that white car and like I said
we have people set up and then once that
car comes you're like okay so they'll
stop the car and we'll see if it's my
suspect my the guy who I've been talking
to because I don't have their picture so
you know you're you know who you're
expecting to show up so once they do
they
and I called the phone and you put the
puzzle pieces together yeah so a lot of
them would not know that I was they were
talking to a cop until it was court time
and they're like oh and you show up and
I'm so turned on right now I love like
god damn she's [ __ ] hot in uniform to
dog I wouldn't fall in love I don't care
I would go to jail for you if I was did
you get cussed out like in court did it
they ever confront you because of the
shock not confront me I mean they did
try to fight it like no like that's
embezzlement not embezzlement like
entrapment and but it's not because
everything we do is legal like you're an
idiot like you like if I would have been
real like not real life but like a real
live girl who you was really willing to
get pimped out by you like you would
have done it but fortunately it was me
and it wasn't it was my job to do that
and that's why I can joy doing it
because I was like you're an [ __ ]
like I just saved a girl or girls you
you know pimping out so I enjoy doing
that and then I had the other portion
going back to you as I actually was able
to walk out on the street and pretend I
was over a live prostitute but that was
mainly to get the John's the guys who
pay for sex and sadly it's really big
like very very very big in Compton and
on in LA there's two streets that are
very common that are known as the blades
that's where you you can be driving on a
normal day and you will see these girls
like with fishnets just fishnets and
like a to table we're half naked and
you're goes like right so they really
actually look cuz I used to live in a
neighborhood that had a street that was
very well-known for prostitutes but they
were dressed normally they weren't
dressed like prostitutes I'm surprised
that they still dress like like full-on
prostitutes yeah I mean you have some
that oh they're like all smeared and
shine maybe but no like you
dress it up like literally there in like
body laces laces or just which is very
bleep yeah like they don't care yeah
they're happy I just put these flowers
of today falling and I'm just at every
time it falls my heart breaks a little
bit because they're thought they're
falling for you so I'm like madly in
love right now one thing I want to know
is though like how come these girls make
it so obvious and why don't the cops
just pick them up in the restaurant
everyday like why is this blade thing
like still such a theme like what
actually that's a good question law
enforcement they do have operations that
they conduct to arrest these women
unfortunately we're in California I
won't get too much into politics but
it's a misdemeanor for prostitution it's
a simple ticket and goodbye they're
releasing a few hours in there to jail
for that the only way to go to jail for
like a long time is if they've
accumulated like numerous arrests and
the judges like done like you do not
learn your lesson or they have warrants
because they just fail to appear but
other than that it's just a simple
misdemeanor and that's why the
repercussions are not that bad that
that's why these girls are it's nothing
to them they just hate it or what
something like how do you get rid of
that once John's probably [ __ ] pay
for it of anything right Holly or their
pimps when they go to court the judge
pretty much tells them yeah what their
repercussion is if they have to pay any
fees or what they're giving them as a
consequence but everyone's different I
wonder what happens to the prostitutes
like once you get these these pimps what
happens to the girls that are under
their belt oh yeah they're like free
range like ya know your team next time
know so I'm a [ __ ] terrible person
sorry I'm just so nervous around you
sadly even though these guys treat these
girls horrible they're very loyal to
them okay God really yes they're very
loyal to them and you'll see them
they'll get like their pimps names Oh
Lord is back home syndrome almost Yeah
right I do
so how does it work like is the pimp
literally falling them to every call yes
and then if they have like 20 girls like
how do they really protect them like
what does that mean is it that the girl
will give them the details so that the
pimp can track the guy down later or
like what is the pimp how is he really
acting the girls yeah so pretty much the
girls you know walking the street
whatever trying to catch her a date and
the pimp is around the area where he has
visual of her so in case John tries to
get crazy with them or not another pimp
tries to come and take their girl then
they're there for the protection that's
pretty much how it works so sometimes
certain areas where there they're
walking belongs to a pimp like that's
his yeah so for a girl of a prostitute
it's she's it's called a renegade
meaning she doesn't have a pimp oh my
god yeah well yeah free range emcees a
borough that they have not seen in on
the blade then if the girl looks at him
and makes eye contact that means ok
she's choosing up she wants to drafted
oh good one and then if she looks down
and just keeps walking that means she
has some hemp so don't
wow I take a baseball game like [ __ ]
doing all these wait what if you're a
renegade and then you know this and then
you just pretend that you have a pimp so
you look down all the time you just walk
away a lot of girls that's the kind of
sad part I also got to talk to a lot of
them they get beat up a lot or they get
robbed by these pimps because they know
they don't have anyone watch oh you
don't even want to do that yet no but a
lot of the girls this is their only way
of income they have kids at home so they
do this like at 3:00 4:00 in the morning
well your kids are asleep so they're out
there like that's I don't see his way to
get money I don't understand like in the
age that the information technology age
we have social media we have all this
stuff like why are girls still walking
the street like they could be cam girls
they could do all this stuff like right
they could make money less dangerous I
mean growing up in the hood though like
as I grew up in the hood like your
bubble like that's
you know that's your reality you don't
know you don't understand that other
people everyone on social media right do
you know even though social media you're
probably in your own bubble exactly but
I feel like even I guess girls from the
hood or whatever like they know that you
can go online and like they don't know
that how old lady words do that though
they would have to build their following
right to get even money if they were
like a sex work online a cam girl
whatever or like what a premium right
whereas on the streets they can just go
and find a dude like your cousin because
your bubble is here there's probably
already P P you probably have like less
than three degrees of separation of
someone that's already in it you know
someone's already telling you like hey
you know it seems like you're struggling
hey I know someone like everyone knows
someone you know I mean so there's no
need for you to have to like venture off
into the internet to do that so I have a
question when you were walking I can
only assume that the amount or the
different kinds of men that approached
you or is like every spectrum yes like
every businessman - like weird
crackheads everything right what was
really support like did you see that was
really surprising did you look like that
guy over there yes and then there's
obviously if when you're when I would be
working in a certain area you know who
lives there like Hispanics blacks or you
know which population is common who you
commonly see there yeah so when you see
like a random white guy you know yeah
why he we definitely say that when we
would see why people are Asian people
are black people in our neighborhood
we're like either he's picking up rent
or they're [ __ ] lost oh there's some
shitty yeah yeah so there'd be times I
think one day one day one day I got try
to get picked up by this older white guy
and they're into the nasty [ __ ] - I was
shocked myself so I like walk with the
car cuz you can kind of like so you're
walking you know walking walking and
they kind of like do like they're like
Kenya can we pretend that I'm one of the
dudes in the car and how would you talk
to me okay oh I like
roleplay auditor cell Europe because
she's like okay what's up and like they
kind of just give you like how much like
straight-up some Jesus no wait do it for
real so she's gonna be the person and
you just you just answer how cool hello
ma'am I respect you very much
how much is it you and I talk to me okay
sorry that's too property
I respect okay uh hey ho how much yeah
well what do you want Jesus works anal
you know I don't do it you know okay
how about just a [ __ ] $20 $40 damn
that's cheap and can we well wait
because I'm not really doing it I just
need to do a deal and that's it oh wait
but do the regular prostitutes that's a
going rate is that the strip the market
Vince what the girl looks like do the
Asian people haggle because I feel like
they would have no over there 25 okay
sorry do they pay you up front so this
is the thing oh I never got the money
my goal was just see what they want
mm-hmm and how much are they gonna pay
because they're paying you mention
they're paying you for sex clearly so
then be like okay like meet me in the
alley and he'll be like okay maybe like
cuz I don't want the cops to see me I'd
pretend to walk you know and then next
thing you know the cops get them oh my
god what were you saying about going
back that you were saying the white ones
other nasties all right yeah the
craziest request oh so it was an older
guy he was like in his 60s oh so he came
he pulled up in a really nice new room
Mercedes so I was like okay this guy has
money like this he knows what he's here
for
so sir sure enough he rolls down his
window and he's like come here so I
walked to his car and I like approached
him and boom he just had his whole like
penis off guard I was just like wow Oh
what you're ready and he could move on
oh I think carry yes and
I mean that and then one time was scary
moment I was walking and is blacked out
car just came up to me and because it's
all getting infested in asserting in
games like cleaned that type of area
like your might you should be my [ __ ]
why are you on my blade whatever so it
was a blacked out car and there was like
four males inside the car and one of
them stuck his head out and just started
like banging army and I was just saying
you know II was ain't telling me his
gang oh you know and I was just like oh
my god pretty much that's telling you
like oh you're about to get shot oh yeah
yes I was in there posited so my head
was just like oh my god I'm gonna get
shot I'm gonna get shot right now so I
just walked away because we have cars
that like are watching us so I was like
okay I don't care I'm gonna blow my
cover but I I don't feel safe yeah so
there's those times but you always have
a back-up plan and you just have to
think about those things has been being
in a cover for nine months is a long
time
did it ever take any like mental
emotional toll on you after a while no
and that's actually why they only do it
for nine months and then they know it
can be I see yeah mentally hairy well
yeah that note we're gonna take a quick
ad break and we're gonna talk about
third love no titties speaking of I love
you here's third love just like
aggressively hitting well just talking
about the cops that support her we're
gonna talk about the things that's a
beautiful yeah beautiful beautiful I
love it
so third love is a bra like you could go
and find bras here and they also have
underwear too but yeah I could take a
quick quiz and find your perfect fit and
they also they have way more sizes and
other brands so even have half cup sizes
oh yeah so you can definitely find the
exact fit for your body and for your
boob shape because apparently there's
weight like so many different boob
shapes yours are different than mine
they are yeah I like how you looked at
my boobs I did you know mine are bell
shape oh nice those are mine hear that
gentlemen bell shape now you know
when Christmas comes I want to rock
those they think you're so gay you're
very happy anyway so you can skip the
trip to go and measure yourself and find
out what's the perfect fit they will
deliver right to your door and what else
sorry
and returns and exchanges are completely
free and easy so if you end up getting
receiving a bra that doesn't match your
exact like you can return and exchange
it for free and it is really hands-down
the most comfortable bra you will own
absolutely I know I have a bunch of bras
at my house right now that I'm not using
but because I spent so much damn money
on it I'm like I refuse to throw it away
but honestly I'm only using my third
love bras right now like how many bras
do y'all have that you they're like [ __ ]
it just doesn't fit right
I recently Marie Kondo all the bras and
just cut my third love damn it I got it
I'm actually wearing it they're live
underwear right now cuz I have underwear
that yea is so comfy how do I get one so
you go to third law third love.com slash
b tch and you can get 15% off your first
purchase that is third love.com slash b
tch for 15% off today not tomorrow thank
you
third love is a great love but you would
be my first love all right back to it
yeah what were we saying emotional tools
rightly ah well I know you're in a
relationship too did that take any sort
of toll in that yo your man is like
laying in bed next to you and you're
like texting that's crazy
if I were him I'd be like hey tell him
that you eat ass what happens that would
be mine I'm very lucky actually
my boyfriend's really supportive he knew
was my job and it was and he knew that
Michael he's actually in law enforcement
as well so he was very understanding he
knew that my goal was to arrest these
guys and I had to do what I had to do
obviously it's kind of awkward like
hearing you know oh how much do you
charge for this but you would hear that
no no
I mean he would hear the pimps like talk
to me and he'd be like these [ __ ]
but he's like you better arrest him I
know better more motivation yeah so he's
very supportive since the beginning and
then so all I would do is like if they
call when I was at home with him I just
have to go to the other room I like talk
to these guys but I'd be like okay this
is so weird but I that's how I was he
was just very supportive and I remember
you mentioning the first time we met and
we had this conversation you ended up
saying that you can only do it for a
certain amount of time because it really
does take a toll so do you know people
that are just constantly an undercover
is it like gonna norm to only do this
first certain amount of time for the
position that I was in it's only it's a
nine-month rotation because it's tiring
and then like you kind of get not
drained but you kind of think your work
home with you you do and then like you
have you have to be on it like they
reply you have to reply and you have to
be on your phone at all time so it takes
a lot of time on duty off duty and it's
just draining so that's why it's only
for nine months and I enjoyed it for my
nine months and yeah it's a really great
experience so aside from the
prostitution and all that stuff this is
a really male-dominated you know like
industry yeah how was that did you did
it was it hard for you in the beginning
of the police academy and then just
dealing with the so much men that this
posture yeah were you treated
differently did you feel you know
anything at all
as a woman in this career you have to
work twice as hard because when you're a
female mm-hmm - you're always gonna be
like question like can you do this job
like murders or just just enjoy everyone
overall and your peers too and then you
also have the women in law enforcement
that see us competition like Katt the
cattiness I'm sure that's everywhere
like you have your haters but it's
mainly like the cattiness like hey like
word like you said in a male-dominated
we should support each other because
it's hard like you've been through it or
I'm going through it like help each
other out because it's hard it's very
hard as a woman one I'm very petite tiny
on five - I'm like 100 and right now I'm
very tiny but I'm
about 120 pounds not only do I get like
question but I like the bad guys but a
lot of things is your command presence
like the way you speak to people and how
you like put your foot down determines
okay are they gonna Punk you or can you
Punk me right now yeah okay so and you
pull me over
that's probably CHP but Punk me I mean I
would so I'm very nice actually the way
Seoul can resist yeah this looks like
biggest thing so what if Gio is being a
[ __ ] to you yeah that's what I'm gonna
be a [ __ ] to you okay let me see give
me something like what would you ask me
I mean uniforms I have to be very
professional okay I work a lot of law
enforcement agencies are recorded so
there's only so much you can do and
people take advantage of that or pretend
like they're super like they know the
law of what we can and can't do yeah and
social media is huge dan use immediately
there like this yeah what are you gonna
do about it yeah like you can't take me
out of my car like I'm not on parole
probation you don't have a warrant but
hey those are not the only reasons why
we can pull you out of your car there's
Kate a lot of case loss and there's a
lot of reasons one the area you work in
it can be gang infested there's just
lots of gangs and maybe there was a
shooting last night and the car matches
the description of the vehicle that shot
the rounds you you don't know like a lot
of people will question our authority
and because of everything going on in
the world it doesn't help it but as a
female I do get questioned like oh or
I'll get like told by a lot of gangster
guys like Oh where's your partner like
aren't you scared like aren't you scared
and I'm really psychological yeah but at
the end of the day as a female I also
use that to my advantage a lot of these
guys you know you kind of use your
resources like hey yeah like where can I
find this where can I do this so you use
it to your advantage
it can either go sideways or you can
like I said like if you're nice then
we're gonna be nice at the end of the
day just simply listen to what the cops
tell you or ask you a lot of people
freaked out like oh my god why do you
have your gun out hey dude we work in
the hood like oh I don't know you I
don't know what is inside of your car I
what I'm approaching until I feel that
I'm safe then okay then we are saved
like The Situation's okay sometimes cops
would just want to be like hey do you
have a valid driver's license is this
your vehicle is your registration
up-to-date oh yes
just say yes ma'am yes sir just be like
yes just answer the questions in a
respectful manner and you're gonna get
it all right so you like have a good
night
know if you're an [ __ ] and you
challenge us to what we can and can do
it's like a lot of cops don't even like
to give tickets but people how do I say
it they push it like they test is of
what we can and can do and hey you're
gonna earn yourself a ticket people are
just making it worse on themself when
they could just be like yes sir no sir
all right yeah so a lot is just
listening and just answer the questions
it's very simple but people like to
challenges because they want to act like
they know everything and like hey you
can't do that you're violating my rights
I'll keep doing your research yeah you
get nervous like being a cop I don't
know if you've gotten pulled over but if
you haven't let the manager imagine you
will you have do you get nervous as well
yes Highway Patrol pulls me over has
pulled me over a few times man used to
like get nervous get behind it you're
like oh my god
even if I were you I'd be like hahaha
I'm gonna wait for him to get out of his
car I'm gonna sit back and I'm gonna be
like there was a moment at this um she
was like a judge or something like very
very high up I think we talked about
yeah and these two cops pulled her over
and she was black and they just pulled
over us like oh there was something
wrong your trunk she's like oh yeah
really and then they're like oh we see
that you have something whatever in your
car what do you do for the government
she's like I'm blah blah whatever
highest position that you should be
afraid of but they're like my god oh
she's like can I get your business cards
please and they're like here you go have
a nice day and they just left there
alone I would relish in that power this
is why I'm not in power all right I
would have you the [ __ ] out of it so
that's good to know that you also get
nervous yeah
even know why I mean I don't do anything
wrong like I everything's in order I
have my registration just paid for but
for some reason I like freak out my
armpits get all sweaty and spicy spicy
I get prickly armpits oh yeah like my
armpits are getting like really prickly
I know how to describe it
I saw someone write it on Twitter that I
was spicy armpits and I'm like I know
exactly we're doing oh I get I get what
you're saying though because like I'm
from Texas so then coming to LA I always
hear about LAPD I'm like oh I'm so
nervous now like living in LA like a the
cops here probably crazy like they deal
with gangsters and like but then the
other day the first time I had an
interaction with a cop I'd like made an
illegal u-turn and he just kind of like
put his lights on he goes hey that was
an illegal u-turn don't do that and I
was like huh am I getting a ticket and
he goes no I got other [ __ ] to do I was
like that was dope like I was like so
scared my first interaction with the
LAPD but it was fine yeah so warning
yeah they're really nice like they let
me go when I accidentally ran over a
mattress why would they even pull you
over no Lori was the story was I was
driving and I was driving at the right
speed at the on the freeway and I ran
over like a math like 80 I choose not to
answer that so I called you know I
called my mom like hey there's no
[ __ ] mattress in the middle of the
road on the freeway you guys might want
to do something about that and she's
like oh did you hit him like yeah
they're like oh why don't you pull over
and like make a report whatever I'm like
like I think I should - do whatever and
this was like 2:00 in the morning and
they pulled me out and then they met me
in a parking lot and the two cops came
out they're like hey listen let's not
report this and I'm like why he goes
because technically it's your fault
you should have been driving slow enough
to be able to see it I was like oh
consider an accident yeah
ah nothing happened no like have a good
day but I have a question um do you
notice that people maybe like either
within your family or oh my god are you
in my [ __ ] head right now I'm in
there I'm in there okay go and finish my
sentence your family your friends or
anyone to use to feel it they treat you
different with my [ __ ] question get
out you baby
yeah because I mean like I have friends
and families from different backgrounds
right like like a legal Saudi do you
notice that they treat you differently
not differently but I mean when I first
got into law enforcement I did lose a
few friendships maybe because yeah yeah
it was quiet I mean you get to see who
your true friends are in supports you
and I was like were there reason I don't
know I girl I would be so candid around
you and then you have those fred-bag oh
sorry Elliot you would be so what deal
okay let me do that we do stupid [ __ ]
like this yeah I'll get you soon um I
would be so candid around you how candid
geo you tell me you had it enough to fix
your [ __ ] teeth speaking of candid
and I missed the Lu completely white
yeah right did you guys know that your
teeth move as you get older yes I feel
them moving right now and I mean not
literally moving right now but they've
shifted how do you get older yeah thing
yeah cuz my teeth actually start
shifting - for real um so I want to get
braces but then I can't really do that
because I can't be a [ __ ] 30 years
old braces right and like people are
gonna be sorry for all the 30 year
thought there that have braces old hos
well you shouldn't have a degree you
should have gotten clear clear
alternative to braces like candid candid
has an experienced orthodontist who is
licensed in your state create a
treatment plan for you they create a 3d
preview of how your teeth will look like
after your treatments are done so you
can
how beautiful you look and that's what
candid did for me so they send you a
mold you mold it and then they build a
treatment plan for you it's a 3d preview
that they approve and they make these
clear aligners and they send them
directly to your house so you don't have
to go to the doctor's office and if
you're like me you don't like leaving
the house right there's no hassle of
going to the orthodontist office and
canid cost about 65% less the Hulman
resource braces were expensive my well
yeah thousand dollars I really did you
need them again they were five because I
got the ceramic thingies
[Music]
also it's really awesome because for
every a liner that is purchased candid
donates $25 to smile trained who brings
safe 100% free cleft lip and palate
treatment to children all around the
globe I love it just for that reason
mm-hmm so if you want straighter or
brighter teeth in an average of just six
months learn more at candid co.com slash
b tch and use the code b tch and get $75
off that's candid co.com slash b tch
code b tch for $75 off and fix that
[ __ ] up grill of yours we're not that
candid with you now so you lost a few
friends when you got into on for ya and
then you'll have the random people that
hit you up because they have questions I
have a ticket every ticket I get I'm
gonna call you on now I really can you
get me out of this those people and then
you'll have the ones that are like oh
this happened like what should I do and
you're just like okay or can you help me
with this I wait I haven't talked to you
like yeah you want to talk to me to come
out of the woodwork yes you have those
people as far as my family my family is
very supportive I mean they know that
what I do is not easy and obviously they
see the news and everything going around
so they're like I'm praying for you
that's that's like the biggest thing so
you're just like oh you're supported
yeah especially now how people feel
about cops it must be a lot scarier now
huh yeah
it's hard and kind of going back to the
topics you guys I forgot who asked about
like being a female so being a female in
this male-dominated career you have to
work not only twice as hard but you have
to show not only your male partners and
the bad guys that you're not just a
pretty face you're not just here to like
find a husband or look cute in this
uniform cuz of Gina then yeah female
Bob's that like use their uniform as
platform to you know just get the
attention yeah look man there's like
other ways to do that besides going
through a police academy and possibly
getting killed like you know yeah that's
a lot of [ __ ] work it is but a lot of
girls that's what they use it like the
uniform for the modeling like hey girl
like go out there and put someone in
your back seat go after it actually
patrol streets and do what your job if I
do yeah make a difference exactly so
it's hard because a lot of guys if they
see you they're gonna think all all the
guys are gonna help or they're could
help her they're gonna do stuff for them
we're gonna take care of her so they're
thinking oh she's gonna have it easy but
then you have girls are like no like I
want to work hard I want to go and
arrest bad guys take gangsters to jail
alright like arrest drug dealers you
know do all this but so you have to work
twice as hard and be like I'm not just a
pretty face
I'm not just using the uniform to get a
husband or find someone on department or
something you actually that's so that's
what you're beating and then you know
you just don't don't want to fall in
that stereotype so those girls a girl
the little bunny from Zootopia there's
something that you mentioned that you
wanted us to talk about specifically
[Applause]
lots of [ __ ] cops yeah oh wait wait wait
would just classifier I don't like one
car it was only one turned into a cop oh
okay so my very first highschool
boyfriend I found out like just last
week I went on Facebook and I found out
like like 16 year old boyfriend very
first one he's a he's a sheriff now or
something in Texas and I was like oh I
guess it's too too common okay
and I did I did wish that he had left
some of the uniform on it sadly I don't
blame or too much I never got to have
the uniform experience I want them to
take everything off but the belt you
know you been a bad girl honey finally
tells are my fetishes for you to be in
jail do you guys do any of the
prostitute outfit fishnets on girl just
don't send this to your parents and yeah
question for you no I watch a lot of Law
& Order SVU so if you're my I did do I'm
crying out in some cases I am available
so are you gonna be like a district
attorney are you gonna be like a public
defender
oh no public DA I can't do it
oh no that's the fence are you helping
the defense or are you helping the good
people not your defense I can't do it
maybe stainability do it yeah I've
watched enough I know you guys don't
like him yeah I never did that I can't
do a devil's advocate dude I don't
understand that whole move what were you
doing I was trying to get a job and I
was flirting with her oh yeah I'm just
saying I've watched every every season
of SVU I know what I'm doing how do you
feel about cop movies and TV shows do
you ever see shouldn't you like
so [ __ ] stupid yeah it's really what
and it's funny because you'll see like
their tactics and you're like oh my god
we do not do that isn't that a good
thing they're not showing what you're
actually doing
yeah I guess in a way it is but then it
just makes it seem like we do dumb stuff
just pops was that what have you guys
seen the other guys when he shoots a gun
like that like on Brooklyn nine-nine no
the other guys with Will Ferrell yeah
damn but yeah well like what dumb [ __ ]
have you seen just like certain things
people do like just searching people or
when you're talking to a bad guy just
letting them walk like oh no you go
hands-on and then you talk in the
backseat oh you're just like like you
kind of get anxiety like oh my god what
are they oh my god and then but they
don't pay it's a movie or it's a TV show
what about the show cops so those are
different departments different
departments have different policies and
they have different training and their
tactics are different so every
departments different of how they
approach different situations so
depending where they work oh that makes
sense yeah so different departments
reduce different certain things nobody
knows the rest of the lyrics after that
what you're gonna do when you come from
I know who sings that song though I
think it's inner circle Oh
google it tell me if I'm right or wrong
anyway um since your parents were really
scared of you going into law enforcement
how would you feel about your kids going
to law enforcement that's a good
question
that's all I have baby well because me
and my boyfriend are both cops I mean we
would kind of not not that we would say
it's bad but we know like how bad it is
and especially nowadays how bad it is
with everything going on at the end it
you have to support your child like my
mom support him even though she hated me
doing this job but I wouldn't recommend
it yeah only because
it's crazy like go do something else
like you wouldn't recommend it if
they're not passionate about it right
right right yeah I mean if they want to
do it hey like your mom and dad do it
like you can't say notes I feel so bad
for your children's significant others
and they start dating for the first time
oh my god and both like they come over
for the first time and it's both cops
you know that scene from bad boys oh
yeah oh my god yeah I've went to her
house and her dining table there's just
one light here what do you want oh [ __ ]
now I'm just kidding you never went to
her house yeah dammit I was thinking so
hard of that joke afraid I was gonna add
I thought about that my first boyfriend
like in high school come over and both
men were cops I would be [ __ ] bricks
man I'd be so scared but you know what's
like the funny part I mean there's
I mean cops are different everyone's
different but we even though we're both
cops we don't like to show or when we're
off show that we are comes because
you're an easy target there's more
people that don't like you than people
that do like you and at the end of day
you don't want to have to keep like
watching it back yeah you just want to
go enjoy dinner or go to the store I
mean there are certain things you can't
avoid but obviously if you're not
identified as a cop then you can enjoy
life a little bit more but it's like
once people know you're a cop they're
just like oh my god okay like mm-hmm
but so we kind of stay away from like I
mean people would never yeah
publicizing it like I like what you're
doing to bu and so yeah that's kind of
like a perks of being a girl too like
you're at work you don't you have your
slick hair and you know and then you
know oh my god you put it in a bun yeah
and then when you come home do you go
yeah I can only get so turned on if you
stop have their hair down I don't get
they're allowed to military yeah are
their badge bunnies for the girl cause I
think we broke down watch oh yeah I am
now badge bunny that just means you love
cobs and all you date are cops like it
that's like like all you will deign are
cops and they're bad staying in your bed
well that you also have the badge
bunnies at which they're called like how
do I explain it so pretty much talk that
[ __ ] girl they know the guys married and
they're like 30 girls going yeah yeah
just don't care like they don't care
that's messed up in Indian this ring
does not matter like damn they're like
that makes you even hotter
yeah seriously you know do you have a
fetish for that yeah that's like oh yeah
I've heard about that yeah do me get
bothered by people who are like oh you
don't look like a cop that's a useful
thing like knowing yeah I like not
looking like a cop right a good thing
right you just don't I don't know it cuz
I guess a cop has a certain look
but yeah I don't get that yeah you don't
look like a Bertha so I feel like Bertha
is gonna be a cop if she has a buzz cut
that's probably baby what would you say
to someone else we're like coming close
to the end of our podcast but what would
you say to someone that wants to get in
in or a female specifically that wants
to get in on law enforcement are you
like go for a pursue your dream or you
like no be careful both if you really
want to do this and you're kind of
curious do it right along whatever
station or police station that's near
your house you can schedule
all right along and are you just making
appointment like a [ __ ] reservation
yeah pretty much yeah
but yeah you go to a ride um come on you
know I'll send the trunk oh my ability
stuff okay
but yeah go do a ride-along and I will
expose you to to see what they really do
in that black and white car and then
you'll know if it is what do you want to
do or if it's not what you want then
from there obviously depending which
department you want to go to do your
research and really look into it a lot
of people think all you need a degree
you will certain departments do require
but that means you're just gonna get
paid more yeah some all you need is your
GED or your high school diploma but
obviously like for example I have a
degree I do get paid a little bit more
because of that so hey why not but you
do not need a degree in criminal justice
or any that it's just a plus for you but
yeah do your research and just look at
the requirements because you need to do
like a written test then you have to do
a physical test so then that's gonna you
have to ask yourself okay am i
physically right now for this like you
have to be physically active and workout
and just be ready like to chase some
dude but the physical thing is that for
everything or is that just - they renew
their physical quick good question but
um obviously it's up to the person
some people get comfortable and I will
not say I hope not to say complacent
that they just don't care but personally
I want to be fit and be able to chase
people down not only that but if I get
into a fight or something
be able to do as much as I can to
survive because at the end of day I want
to go home I want my partners to go home
and if I fell as a partner and god
forbid like my partners gets her because
I couldn't do something then I would
feel bad like how am I gonna tell his
family like I was there and I couldn't
do anything because I wasn't able you
know so I think that's a up to the
person if they want to stay physically
active and work on it there's people
that like they stay on top of it and
that's really good because you want to
be able to do all that stuff and
obviously if you're obese or you know
thing there's not so much there's not a
lot you can do yeah yeah that that's
dust cops
yes hard desk jockeys yeah no that's
really beautiful that you put it out
like that because um as we all know like
at least in the media right now
and for quite a bit cops have always
just kind of been looked down upon like
they're always the aggressors or
whatever but it's obviously a handful of
you know bad apples yeah bad apples that
kind of ruin the batch because like you
said I think you know earlier you were
just like we don't know what you're what
threat you're posing to us and right and
you guys already have like a checklist
like you guys already know that bad guys
tend to have expired plates or they tend
to have a taillight that's out like
there's different markers that you look
for what oh [ __ ] you feel attacked I'm
sorry there's like a criteria that
you're like okay see this pattern time
and time again with these type of like
bad people so it's like you're you're
already like at high risk right um so
yeah people just kind of be respectful
like you were saying like not everyone's
an [ __ ] not everyone's a dick like
yes you have your rights but just answer
the question then if you're not guilty
just take it if you're right most of
them like like you go into it because
they just want to help people make a
world a better place yeah you want to
help that lady who keeps getting beat up
by her boyfriend and maybe you're gonna
be that person that's gonna finally
convince her hey it's not worth it like
your kids are not do not like do you
really want your kids to keep growing up
like this and watching your baby daddy
keep beating you and you just never know
obviously you encounter different calls
and some you might make an impact some
she might go back with baby daddy the
next day she might even bail him out
yeah yeah you have those but yeah
definitely like that and all I can say
is like Gio is saying
just listen to what we're telling you we
have seconds to determine what we're
gonna do yeah like we approach these
situations and we have seconds to make a
decision yeah so a lot of people want to
critique obviously like you said there's
a few bad apples we're not all perfect
people make mistakes we're human under
that uniform we're still human and some
people make mistakes but I will say that
as cops like we do have we have to make
decisions in split seconds like
determine okay what are you gonna do
like are you a threat yeah obviously
exactly there's a lot of stress and
you're understaffed it's [ __ ] in the LA
area exactly not only that
times I was speeding and nobody ever
know how much drugs I have in my car
right now yeah so there's bigger fish to
fry too but okay obviously yeah just
stress remember that yeah like trying to
keep yourself safe be nice hug a cop
wait what with consent sorry yeah so
thank you so much you're definitely
inspirational and encouraging and I hope
a lot of females out there feel like
just because you're a female like you
can't do something like obviously from
this podcast we've never ever once have
preached that but just in case that
little voice in your heads like well I
don't know like a cop like I don't know
if I can do it you're you're like a
walking testament that yeah you [ __ ]
can you know yes five to a buck twenty
and she's kicking [ __ ] ass so if
you're on the fence about wanting to do
something physical like that are
something they're putting your life in
danger that way just [ __ ] do it
really want to do it so don't let that
be a crutch and definitely don't let
that stop you so thank you for being
here today and thank you to our sponsors
thanks again to our sponsors function of
beauty third love and candid listeners
will receive 20% off their first order
to redeem head to function of beauty
calm slash b tch and take their hair
profile quiz go to function calm btch
our site function of beauty calm flashy
TCA to get 20% off your custom formula
and third love knows there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they are
offering your listeners 15% of your
listeners who wrote this third love
knows there's a perfect bra for one so
right now they are offering you guys our
listeners 50% off your first order so go
to 3rd love comm / BTC 88 now to find
your perfect fitting bra and get
straighter brighter teeth in an average
of just six months learn more at candid
co.com slash b tch and use code b tch to
get $75 off that that's cat
oh that's candid co.com slash b TCH code
b TCH for $75 off also come on if you
[ __ ] love us which I know you do we
have more for you we actually created a
hey [ __ ] highlights channel on YouTube
we know these podcasts are crazy but
there's always these beautiful moments
and these beautiful hidden gems and we
hand-picked those out for you and we put
them on this special channel for you to
watch and enjoy and share with your
friends it's a hey [ __ ] highlights
channel on YouTube and it's up now so uh
link is in the description and click on
that have a lot of fun and if you
haven't yet please hmm give us five
stars because we know you love us come
on stop playing yourself thank you guys
so much you think sorry
[Music]